Welcome to the session. This is the Mini Symposium on KRAS Targeted Therapies:
Overcoming Resistance.
I know there's a number of other kind of RAS-themed
mini symposiums ongoing, but this is really the best one.
So welcome. I'm here with Dr. Malhotra from City of
Hope. She's going to do our introductions, and then we're going to
call out the speakers, 10 minutes, and five minutes for
questions, and hopefully end on time.
So Dr. Malhotra is going to introduce our topic for today. Thank you, Dr. Malhotra.
Thank you, Dr. Hong, and thank you to all of you for being here.
We really look forward to the interesting data that will be presented
today.
So KRAS, all of you have already heard quite a lot about this, which
is good.
Currently, we only have KRAS G12C
inhibitors approved for pre-treated lung
cancer and colorectal cancer, either as monotherapy or with
EGFR inhibitors. But hopefully that will change
soon now based on all the data that we are seeing, there are a
lot of KRAS inhibitors in development, mutation-specific
pan-KRAS and pan-RAS. So really, what's the
next step? So we really have to come up with effective combination strategies
to achieve those deep and durable responses for our patients, in
addition to minimizing toxicity.
And then end of the day, we really have to find ways to really tailor the
combination to the patient, to their tumor type,
as well as the mechanism of potential resistance.
So in terms of mechanisms of resistance to KRAS inhibitors, they can be
either innate or acquired molecular or
genetic
mechanisms, or they can be adaptive mechanisms of resistance
really manifesting, such as epithelial to mesenchymal
transition, just as an example. So today, we will be reviewing
seven presentations, really presenting novel data, looking
at different combination strategies with KRAS inhibitors.
One potential combination strategy is to combine KRAS
inhibitors with targeting of a downstream target,
and we have two presentations there looking at targeting
PIK3 as well as mTOR in addition to
KRAS.
The second combination strategy is to inhibit potential
adaptive responses that can be a mechanism of
resistance. And here we have two presentations, one looking at
autophagy inhibition, the other looking at targeting the JAK-STAT
pathway. And last but not the least, another combination
strategy is to combine KRAS inhibitors with other
drugs which leverage other cancer-associated
vulnerabilities. And here we have three presentations, two of which
will talk about
targeting DNA damage repair pathway, and then one
presentation will look at oxidative stress, especially that
associated with KEAP1 and Nrf2 resistance.
One request to all the speakers that please try to limit your
presentations to 10 minutes or less so that we have five
minutes after each presentation for question and answer.
So without further delay, we will get started.
Our first presentation is from Dr.
Wen-Hsun Chang from University of North Carolina, who
will be presenting on defining a molecular signature for
KEAP1-Nrf2-mediated resistance to KRAS inhibition.
Dr. Chang.
Okay.
First I'd like to thanks the committee for selecting me to present this talk.
I'm really excited to share our recent progress in understanding
KEAP1-Nrf2-mediated resistance to RAS inhibitions in both
pancreatic cancers and lung cancers.
We started this project really just trying to understand the resistance mechanism
of RAS inhibitors. So we actually first conducted CRISPR screens
using a pancreatic cancer models treated with both
G12D inhibitor MRTX1133 or the
multi-RAS inhibitor RMC7977. And in both
screens, we identified that knockout of KEAP1 are
one of the most potent drivers to promote resistance to
RAS inhibitors in these systems. So we decided to follow that up.
So let me tell you a little bit of the biology of the KEAP1 and Nrf2 pathways.
So KEAP1 is a member of E3 ubiquitin ligase that
will engage Nrf2 and promote its polyubiquitination and
degradation. So in the normal conditions, it will basically keep the Nrf2
expression low. And Nrf2 is a transcription factor, so it will facilitate a
series of transcriptions.
But in cancer cells, loss of function mutation happen on KEAP1 or
gain of function mutation happen on Nrf2 will basically break the
KEAP1-Nrf2 interactions. So in this case, Nrf2 will no longer be
negatively regulated by KEAP1, and it will start to facilitate a
series of gene transcriptions regulated cell survival or
metabolic reprogramming.
In fact, several study has identified that KEAP1 mutation is
associated with resistance to RAS inhibitors.
One of the study nicely described by Dr.
Marcel Nagrat last years, showing that for KRAS
G12C mutant NSCLC patient treated with adagrasib, those patient
with KEAP1 mutation tend to perform poorly, based on the
progression-free survival and overall survival plots here.
And it should also be noted that the KEAP1 mutation actually represent
15% of total NSCLC patient population, which is a
significant patient numbers.Another study
released from Revolution Medicine last year actually shows that for PDAC
patients acquire resistance to erlotinib/racib, some patients actually were
found with KEAP1 truncation, which is very likely a
loss of function KEAP1 mutations.
And also, study has also shown that in the Grade 3 PDAC
tumors, based on IH staining, also found that these tumor has a lot of Nrf2
overexpressions. So based on these clinical studies, we
conclude that the KEAP1 Nrf2 pathway play an important role in
not only regulating cancer progression, but also regulating sensitivity to
RAS inhibitors.
So we decided to get to the bottom of this mechanism.
So we decided first to generate a KEAP1 Nrf2 stable knockout
cell line. Here I'm showing you two examples here.
When we knockout KEAP1, we can see a nice overexpression of
Nrf2,
and its transcription target NQO1 also increase as
well. And when we are challenging these cell line with RAS inhibitor, we
found that the KEAP1 knockout cell line become far less
sensitive to RAS inhibitor compared to the control cell lines.
We moved this model to the NSCLC model, which we have a KP
tumor
allograft model with a control knockout or a KEAP1 knockout.
And as you can see here, the control knockout is highly sensitive to the
G12D inhibitor shown here, but the KEAP1 knockout,
the tumor can still slowly growing under the G12D
inhibitor treatments. So from this experiment, we conclude that
a KEAP1 knockout will promote the resistance to RAS inhibitor in both
lung cancer and pancreatic cancer in vitro and in vivo.
We then ask the question whether Nrf2 is the major player to drive the
resistance. So we generate a KEAP1 Nrf2 double knockout cells, and
as you can see, there are proliferation curve in green.
Pretty much the proliferation curve with KEAP1 Nrf2 double knockout cells
overlap with the control knockouts.
So with that, we conclude that the Nrf2 is the major player to drive
resistance, mediated by KEAP1 knockout.
And since Nrf2 is a transcription factor, we then went on to
characterize the transcriptomic change in PDAC cell line when we
knock out KEAP1. And we did a bulk RNA sequencing
and identify about 1,200 genes significantly upregulated
upon KEAP1 knockout, and about 1,000 genes significantly downregulated.
We then want to ask whether these genes are somehow related to RAS, so
we treat these KEAP1 knockout cells with RAS inhibitors.
And what was interesting here is that we found that these significantly upregulated
genes upon KEAP1 knockout,
65% remain upregulated when the RAS
inhibitor was treated in these cell lines, and only less than
1% of the cells become downregulated, which suggests that these
genes were pretty much independent to RAS signaling pathways.
So we then want to further analyze this angle, and our laboratory
and other groups has identified that reactivation of RAS-ERK,
activation of MYC transcription factors, and activation of TEAD transcription
factor can promote resistance to RAS inhibitors.
Our group also recently published these studies along with
Paul et al. published this study.
I compare the KEAP1-dependent transcriptome, MYC-dependent
transcriptome, and TEAD-dependent transcriptome.
These three RNA-Seq data set with my KEAP1 knockout data set to
identify how much overlap they have within these four
data sets.
So these network analysis, each dot represent one single genes
regulated by either RAS, MYC, or TEAD, or upregulated by
KEAP1 knockout. You can see there's a lot of overlap between RAS, MYC, and
TEAD, but pretty much the genes regulated by KEAP1 knockout are largely
independent to the RAS, MYC, and TEAD.
So that suggests that KEAP1 knockout regulated transcriptomes, that's
pretty much distinct from the transcriptome mediated by RAS, MYC, and TEAD,
which could also suggest that KEAP1 knockout promote resistance using
distinct mechanisms regulated by other three progress.
We then wanted to generate a focused gene signatures by filtering the
top 200 coding genes from our KEAP1 knockout transcriptomes,
and we decide to name it as a PDAC KEAP1 deficiency gene signatures.
We cross-reference our data with the ENCODE ChIP-seq database and
found that about 50% of the genes are direct Nrf2
target, which means that our signature capture both direct
Nrf2 targets and secondary target as well.
We then look at the patient data treated with adagrasib.
Here we have 10 patients treated with adagrasib, and for those eight
patient who were resistant to adagrasib, we look at their sequencing data
before receive any treatment, and these patients express
higher gene expression of our PKD gene signature compared
to those patient who were sensitive to the drug.
Another data set we look at was published by Simon et al.
at 2023, where they have a KRAS G12C mutant
PDX model RNA-Seq data. And when we look at these RNA-Seq data,
we found that the resistant PDX model has far
higher PKD gene expressions compared to those which were
sensitive to the drug. So from this, we conclude that our
PKD signature is associated with resistance to
RAS inhibitor.
We then trying to identify a
therapeutic strategy to overcome the resistance to
RAS inhibitor mediated by KEAP1 loss or Nrf2 activations.
And it has been reported that KEAP1 loss or Nrf2 activation will
enhance the glutamine metabolism in cancer cells.
Here I'm showing you three examples here.
In our study, we also found that KEAP1 loss promote
glutamine uptake and glutamate secretion in these
PDAC systems that we identified.
So we wanted to leverage these observations, and we use
a-Glutamine metabolism inhibitor DRP104
is a glutamine antagonist that globally targets all the
glutamine-utilizing enzymes. So we want to use this to inhibit the
glutamine metabolism pathways. And this drug is also being
evaluated in several clinical trials, with especially one KPO1-NERV2
alter NSCLC tumor that was recently launched at NYU.
So we decided to combine this inhibitor with the RAS
inhibitors and see if we can overcome the resistance mediated by KPO1
loss or NERV2 activations.
So here we move it to the in vivo model.
Here we have three in vivo models shown here.
We have a PDAC PDX model with NERV2
amplification in these tumors. We have a lung cancer
KP tumor allograft model, and in this model, we have KPO1 knockout,
and we also have a KP tumor model expressing a dominant negative
form of KPO1 R470C.
In all three in vivo experiments, we identified that the RAS
inhibitor plus the DRP104, the glutamine
antagonist, can nicely suppress the tumor growth in all three
models compared to any single agent alone.
So we conclude that we can leverage the glutamine metabolism
dependencies and combine the inhibitor targeting glutamine
metabolism with RAS inhibitors as a way to target KPO1-NERV2
alter tumors.
And this work is in collaboration with Dr.
Andrew Gerri, Brian Wolping, Dr. Thalis
Papagiannakopoulos, and Kwok-Ying Wong from NYU
with this work.
With this, I'd like to conclude my talk.
So I hope I can convince you that we've demonstrated KPO1 loss really
promote resistance to RAS inhibitors.
We identify the signatures that is associated to resistance to RAS
inhibitor, both in patient datasets and in PDX datasets.
And we also directly defined a transcriptome that is distinct.
KPO1 knockout transcriptome distinct from the transcriptome regulated
by RAS, MYC, and TED. And we showed that the
combination of RAS inhibitor with a glutamine antagonist, DRP104,
can potently inhibit the growth of NERV2-activated tumors.
With that, I'd like to thank all the collaborators who contributed to this work.
Thanks to Channing, Adrienne, Clint, and Kirsten for their support to this work.
Addison and Stami in the lab contribute a lot on a lot of
study here. I also like to thank the collaborator from NYU, Thalis,
and Kwok-Ying Wong, and Alec. Our collaborator from University of Cincinnati,
Andrew Walters, and collaborator from Dana-Farber, Andrew Gerri.
And this work has been deposited on bioRxiv here, and this
is my contact information, so happy to take any questions here or
further. Thank you.
If you have a question, please come up to the mic.
Announce your
name and institution, and then you have a question. Yes.
Okay. Dadi Zhang from MD Anderson.
I agree with David. This is one of the best RAS sessions. Yeah.
Okay. Dr. Chang, I think your CRISPR screening
did identify a few key glutathione synthesis genes, right?
GCLCS7A11. Did you try to see whether if
you supplement your cells with glutathione, whether the
differences in sensitivity to the KRAS inhibitors just go
away or...
Do you mean if we supply a lot of the glutamine in the culture condition to
see if-
Not glutamine, I mean glutathione because one of the two top genes that
you identified from your CRISPR screening were involved in the glutathione
synthesis pathways.
We didn't do the experiment, but let me see if this can answer your question.
We see that SLC7A11 is significantly
upregulated, so we try to knock it down to block the glutamine
glutamate
secretions. And that if we knock down SLC7A11, we can
eliminate a glutamine dependency, but that won't reverse the resistance
to RAS inhibitors. So I think
all the glutamine dependence is an observation that we found in these KPO1 knockout
pathways, but that may not be the sole reasons to drive resistance
to RAS inhibitors.
Thanks.
Hi. Tomer from Dana-Farber. Thank you for the beautiful talk.
Following up your talk and Channing's talk from yesterday, you mentioned
the MYC, the Axel, the KPO1, all of these different
drivers for resistance.
Do we think that some of them might converge downstream to
similar resistance pathways, or each one of them,
as far as you can see, is a separate mechanism for resistance?
So based on our network study, we think that activation of
KRAS, ERK, MYC, and TED, they have somewhat converged
to a certain degree and had a lot of overlap.
As you can see in the network plot I just showed, they have a lot of overlapping
genes. But I think what was interesting here is that a KPO1 knockout really
regulated completely distinct transcriptomes compared to the
other three. So to answer your question, I think that RAS, MYC, and TED
may have some significant overlap, but KPO1 knockout
just used probably a very different mechanism to drive
resistance.
Do you think that if you keep the KPO1 knockout, it will eventually
develop another resistance through one of the other
mechanisms? So you haven't seen that?
So we actually try to generate our resistance cell line, and I think in
our experience, the resistance is a mix of a lot of different
mechanisms. So in our resistance cell line, we see activation of MYC and TED,
but we can also see the activation of NERV2.
So I think in the resistance
cell line, there is a mix of a lot of program contribute to the
resistance.
Fabulous. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay. I just have one question, and I may have missed this,
but I know Channing's lab and your lab is focused on
pancreatic, but KPO1 is a much bigger issue in
non-small cell lung. It's in fact about 20% of patients with
KRAS G12C. Did you guys look at this at all in non-small cell
lung with the DSP301 inhibitor plusA G12C
inhibitor at all?
You mean look at the glutamine inhibitor?
In lung cancer cell lines, yeah.
You mean the combination?
Yes.
So the combination actually doesn't work in the 2D cell line very well.
So that's why most of our combination are done in vivo models.
Oh.
In the vivo model, we showed that the pDEK model or the
NSCLC models can all respond to the drug. Yeah.
Both. Okay, great. All right.
Thank you very much again.
Thank you.
All right. Our next speaker is Dr. Bail from Moffitt
Cancer Center, and he's going to talk about selective ULK1/2
inhibitors enhance KRAS pathway blockade and uncover
stress adaptive programs.
Thank you for the introduction and thank you for the committee to
allow me to present my results.
I'm going to present to you today the development of selective ULK1
and 2 inhibitor and their synergy with the KRAS pathway blockade
and how it uncovered the stress adaptive program.
In 2011, two papers came out showing the dependency of
RAS-specific models to autophagy using
SI against ATG5, ATG7, but also
chloroquine and showing a decrease of viability specifically in the RAS
model.
Ten years later, two paper came out in "Nature Medicine" showing the
synergy of
the KRAS pathway blockade with autophagy inhibition.
Here
in pancreatic cancer and in melanoma.
Here was with the ERK inhibitor and hydroxychloroquine, and here with
chloroquine and the MEK inhibitor, trametinib.
Hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine have a lot of off-target effect
and are linked to high toxicity. So we then asked the question,
can we develop ULK1 specific inhibitor to enhance that
synergy?
ULK1 is directly
connected to the MAP kinase pathway through the AMPK/LKB1
axis and can be conversely inhibited by mTOR through the
PI3K pathway.
The knockout of ULK1 is sufficient to abrogate
autophagy as it initiate autophagy first
by phosphorylating its direct target ATG14 and
13. That will lead to the maturation of the autophagosome,
notably by cleaving LC3-1 and LC3-2.
That will lead to the fusion of the autophagosome and the lysosome,
where cell components will be degraded to provide new nutrients for the cells.
We developed 2088 through a structure guide
design in silico
and further structure-activity relationship that were led by two different
assay, LantaScreen and NanoBRET, that both use a
fluorescent tracer that will get displaced by the inhibitor.
Then we can
test different concentration and quantify the affinity.
Here we compare to other ULK1 inhibitor and we observed that we had a better
affinity in the NanoBRET in the cells with
2088 over other ULK1 compound.
We then tested the effect of 2088 on the direct target of
ULK1,
ATGs 13. We can increase the phosphorylation by putting the
cells in starving condition or KRAS
pathway treatment. Here with trametinib, the MEK
inhibitor. And we can see the inhibition of phospho-ATG13
that is concentration dependent.
We then tested the effect on the downstream pathway, the autophagy flux.
For that, we use the vector expressing LC3B
in fusion with EGFP and mCherry.
EGFP is acid sensitive and we will
lose the fluorescence when the autophagosome will fuse with the lysosome,
being acid environment. We can increase the
overall autophagy flux by putting the cells in starving condition
and increasing the overall
fluorescence.
With the control of bafilomycin that will block the fusion between the
autophagosome and the lysosome.
We can see all the vesicle staying yellow and 2088
completely abrogating the autophagy flux.
We then tested the synergy between 2088
and the KRAS pathway blockade.
Here in the non-small cell lung cancer H2030 with
trametinib, the MEK inhibitor, and 2088.
We used the model of Luovei to calculate the combination index,
and here it's represented in blue, the high synergy.
We also tested in vivo in the xenograft model Calu-1
with sotorasib and 2088 and we see
the synergy and the tumor growth inhibition in the
combination of sotorasib 2088 over sotorasib alone.
Because we were curious about the mechanism of the synergy, we looked
into the drug-tolerant persist cells.
In 2021, a paper came out on colorectal cancer cells
treated with chemotherapy irinotecan.
And they were observing no clonal selection linked to any
genetic event, but rather a pathway activation, notably
of a decrease of mTOR activity and an increase of
autophagy.
We then wonder if the synergy that we see would be linked to
any drug-tolerant persist cells.
In order to study that, we use the DNA barcoding technology
that we introduced in the cells through an antiviral transduction at a
specific MOI so that every cell only contain one
specific barcode.
We then injected those cells into the mice and we can follow
the evolution with treatment that will go through minimal residual
disease, but resistance will eventually arise and we can
quantify the clonal evolution through DNA
sequencing.So we realized a new in vivo
study with the CADU1 DNA barcoded cells.
And once again, we were seeing a significant tumor growth inhibition
linked to a better overall survival and a delay of any
resistance.
We sequenced the DNA at the beginning of the study at
minimal residual disease and at the end of the study, comparing
treated with sotorasib and vehicle.
In order to quantify the clonal diversity, the biodiversity,
we used the mathematical formula of the Shannon diversity index.
The higher the index is, the more uniform the distribution will be.
And when the distribution is skewed, the Shannon
diversity index will get reduced,
showing a prevalence of a specific clone or a specific barcode over
the other.
Here, the result of the study,
represented by beads proportional to the size and prevalence to
the entire population. Here,
at the beginning of the study, at minimal residual disease, and
at the end of the study, comparing treated and untreated.
Then we looked at the Shannon diversity index.
Beginning of the study, and we see a reduction with the course of the
study.
But what we were observing is that there was no significant
difference between untreated and treated with sotorasib,
suggesting there was no clonal selection with
sotorasib treatment.
In conjunction to the DNA barcode sequencing, we
realized RNA bulk, RNA-seq, and process pathway
analysis. Here, I'm presenting to you the results of minimal
residual disease compared to beginning of the study.
And curiously, we were seeing a lot of the same pathway of
the study that I just showed you on colorectal cancer cells,
DTP treated with irinotecan.
And a lot of the pathway that we're correlating
were pathway that are often described in DTP study, such
as the NOTCH signaling, the
negatively enriched mTOR signaling,
Myc target, but also specific metabolic
signatures such as glycolysis and oxidative phosphorylation.
That's here.
In conclusion, I showed you the development of the selective
ULK1 and 2 inhibitor, how they synergize with sotorasib.
Our research suggests that it's not
linked to any specific clonal selection, but rather pathway
activation that are correlating with other DTP studies.
I would like to thank everyone
that was involved in the study. And here's the QR code of
the paper that I presented in the first part if you
want to know more about the chemistry.
And thank you, and I'm happy to take any question.
So while we are waiting for more questions, I do have a question.
So you showed the data of using autophagy inhibition,
in combination with the G12C inhibitor, which is sotorasib in lung cancer.
Have you looked at combining the ULK1 inhibitors
with
other RAS inhibitors, especially non-G12, like G12D
or pan-RAS inhibitors?
So we didn't do any G12D or any
RAS, but we did do ERK inhibitor or MEK inhibitor,
yes.
But
this is interesting. This would be definitely worth trying, yes.
Hi, Tomer from Dana-Farber. So it seemed that the autophagy
state makes the cells a little bit less aggressive, and then you
inhibit them. I'm wondering,
do you think that resistance state is reversible and
later on the cells would go back to the aggressive state?
Or that will remain like that,
non-aggressive but resistant state
going ahead?
Yes. Thank you for that question. It's definitely interesting.
So the DTP seem to be a reversible state, and it's
definitely not aggressive, but it is during also this period
that they can acquire
other
maybe genetic event or other pathway activation such as EMT,
where we see later on what other people are
called DTEP, extended persisters, that they lose this
reversibility. So I think it would be a nice therapeutic
window if we could fully get rid of those DTP.
I'm curious, if you would take the ULK activated
cells and try to treat them with KRAS inhibitor only
later on, I don't know, a week and a month, do you think they might be
desensitized again?
So those are interesting studies. Yeah.
Because for the autophagy and the KRAS inhibitor,
I didn't do those experiments, but
the time component of should we stop
KRAS and put on the ULK1 inhibitor,
then put KRAS again, put ULK1 inhibitor, this would be interesting to
test, yes.
Thank you.
Hi, Caleb Chang from University of Michigan.
Great talk, and I'm just wondering if you've done any kind of benchmarking
experiments comparing your ULK inhibitor compared to other ULK inhibitors or
chloroquine in terms of their
effects on the cells to imply whether
the ways you inhibit autophagy impact
how the cells respond to it?
So for a few assays, we did compare
to other ULK1 inhibitor. We did not do
any combination in vivo with newer compound,
but we actually right now trying to target
ULK1 with different modalities. We actually developed
a PROTAC against ULK1. So that will be interesting also
to see the difference
of the consequences on the DTP or the synergy.
Yes.
Thank you.
Dr. Bail, I just have one last question for you.
In pancreatic cancer, there was a lot of hope
initially with chloroquine in combination with chemo.
There were some other ULK1 inhibitors,
and it just never panned out in pancreatic.
There was not much that
activity, even though the initial smaller studies.
Why do you think that is? What's your hypothesis?
Is it just inhibiting just autophagy with
chloroquine or ULK1 in itself, you really do have to add
a RAS inhibitor?
What would your hypothesis be why those studies failed?
So I didn't do many testing on pancreatic cancer,
but I did a few, and there was definitely a synergy.
However, I think we are still missing some specific
biomarker in order to pinpoint when and how
we can target autophagy. And I think
this is what's missing. But about chloroquine and hydroxychloroquine, a lot
of studies are coming out also to talk about the
non-on-target effect linked to the answer of
chloroquine and hydroxychloroquine.
And I think, yes, developing a more on-target
inhibitor like ours or like the one that is in clinical study right now
will hopefully bring us answer.
Thank you.
Right. Our next speaker is Di Zan from
Shanghai ChemPartner, who will be talking about modeling of acquired
resistance to multi RAS inhibitor RMC-6236
in KRAS mutant pancreatic cancer.
Thank you.
Thank you, everyone. And it's very nice to be back at AACR
and back to sunny San Diego.
I live in the UK, so we have to start with the weather.
And so today I'm going to quickly go through some data
our team has worked on. We're trying to do things a little
bit backwards. So we got some data from publications
about RMC-6236 and
from Revolutionary Medicine. And then we look things backwards, see
how we can go a step forward to help
with resistance. And first, I don't have any
financial relations to disclose.
So we all know PDAC is a very difficult to treat cancer, and
about 88% PDAC tumors harbor the
KRAS mutation. And isn't just a marker in this
disease. So it's actually the central engine that drive the
disease progression.
So KRAS has been undruggable for so long.
And so successful pan-KRAS inhibition is the holy
grail of pancreatic cancer therapy.
An RMC-6236 from Revolutionary Medicine
is a molecular glue. So it's an orally
bioavailable multi-selection RAS ON inhibitor.
Is the first pan-KRAS inhibitor that directly targets the
GTP-bound state, or RAS ON.
It blocks effector binding and therefore inhibits the downstream RAS
signaling.
Phase one and Phase Ib trial has a very promising
safety and efficacy data, and therefore it has
earned the Organ Drug Designation and Breakthrough Therapy
Designation.
However, the early sequencing data that has been published
indicate that resistance may be the blockage for long-term
efficacy.
Depending on where we look at, there are three
potential
mechanisms that may lead to
resistance of this inhibitor. So one is the KRAS-centric
alteration. So KRAS gene amplification or specific
secondary mutation such as the Y64, and
downstream bypass mechanisms like BRAF
and MAP2K1, or also the upstream
compensatory signaling like RTKs.
So first, our team have a look at the Y64 inhibitor.
So we started with some biochemistry assays.
We look at the CYPN and 626 KRAS. We
can see with the wild type G12D on the top row
and the wild type G12C.
Okay, this works. So it's very good
binding. But when we introduce the Y64
mutation, the binding has been completely abolished.
And after that, we look at the tri-complex with molecular
glue and their interaction with RAF.
So with the existence of CYPN, we can see in wild
type, a very good binding.
But when we introduce the Y64 mutation, the binding again
has abolished.
Biochemistry assay is initial, gives some idea.
Then when we move downstream, we move into cells.
So we generate some Y64D resistant
mutation cell lines. We use Mira-PaCa2, which is G12C
mutation, and ASPC-1 and Panc-1, which harbors
G12D mutation.And so
this mutation cell lines and then we run a
3D and cell Titer Glow assay to check and the
response to different inhibitors.
We can see the Y64 cell lines have very high
level resistance, and we have drastic assay 50
elevation and significant drop in maximum.
So this is a line, maximum growth to inhibition to just
about 35% to 50%.
Look data a bit closely, and so we see the top
one is Mir-Parka2 and the bottom one is
ASPC1. So we can see the cell lines with the
mutation are resistance to
6236, while the wild type, we see very good
efficacy.
And then following on, and we did some downstream
analysis. So Western blot data has confirmed the binding
assay and cell growth, confirming that
once we introduce Y64D, we can see the p-ERK, which is a
main and binding factor. So we see with wild type,
it's nearly gone. And with Y64D, and they're still there.
And ASPC1 tell the same story. With Y64
mutation,
the 6236 is not working.
Multi in vivo tell us more or less the same story, and in the
Mir-Parka2 and subcutaneous tumor, we can
see with two doses, low and high,
6236 completely remove the tumor growth and
is flat lined.
We introduce three different mutations, 64C,
64D, and 64H.
There's still some efficacy, but we can see the efficacy has
been significantly reduced. Tumors are still growing.
And ASPC1, more or less the same story.
So we look at ASPC1 with wild type
ASPC1, and 6236 kill the tumor,
while when we introduce the mutation,
and the tumor are continued growing.
We also have looked at other pan-KRAS inhibitors.
And so this is G12D inhibitor, and this is
pan-KRAS inhibitor. So we look at this, we can see with the
introduce and 64 mutation, we can see
the
efficacy of both inhibitor has been abolished
or reduced, while the Merck inhibitor is still working.
So this actually gave us an idea with potential
combination therapy. The second
half, we move forward a little bit.
We're trying to build a resistant cell line by drug escalation,
so which is better mimic the clinical situation.
We keep the cells in escalation dose for quite long
time. So in this case, it's about nine months.
So we generated the Mir-Parka, what we call Mir-Parka
resistant cell lines and the PANK1 resistant.
We can see under 3D culture, so
the top one is Mir-Parka. We see the IC50
has significantly increased. And then
RMV6236 in PANK1 tells you a very
similar story. So we will
call it spontaneous resistant models.
We look at
the downstream signaling in
6236 induced resistance models.
So on this one, we look at this two band. This is wild type.
So still great efficacy is abolished the
phospho-ERK and expression. And
at four hours, we do see a reduction, and here we
don't really see it's not working as well.
So this one is not working as well compared to wild type.
And so that's some efficacy data. So efficacy data gives the idea.
We know those cell lines are actually not really
working. Well, then we trying to figure out why.
We know Y64 is probably one mutations that
will impact how
this
compound or this molecular glue becomes resistance.
And so what we have done is we have run some multi-omic data
analysis, and with the escalation dose resistant cell line
compared to wild type.
We look at various things, so in the genomic level.
So we can see KRAS stability. KRAS
west has confirmed there's really no secondary mutation in the
KRAS coding sequence.
Also,
we didn't really see any shift in the KRAS copy number, and that
rules out the gene amplification loss as driver.
However, when we look at phosphorylation and RNA
validation, we do see a lot of pathways has changed.
So the data on this page is Mir-Parka2, and this
is a G12C cell line. We see FGFR1
induction. We see FRS2
activation. We also see SHP2 and
integration and AKT activation. So a lot of pathways have changed.
PANK1 cell line shows a slightly different story.
Again, it's a multilayered adaption.
So we can see RTK bypass and where the
FGFR2/KIT/TGFA axis.
We can see subclone reinforcement, and we can see adaptive
protection.
And so all this tell a story. So the pan-KRAS
inhibitor and this molecular glue
will...We have seen hint of resistance, but
it's unlikely it's a single event-driven resistance.
So we can see the oncogene pathway mutations such as KRAS
and G12X, BRAF V600, et cetera,
and they will lead to resistance.
And it may bypass the BTK's mediated IMC
6236, and the KRAS G12X are
also sensitive to MEK inhibitor, which is a good news.
So that's indication for the future
potential combination therapies.
And the last slide is, I just want to thank the team who actually done all
the hard work, and it's now me here trying to take their credit.
You can meet them and at booth 4415.
And I also want to thank to Unity Biolabs, who have done all the genomic
data for us. Thank you very much.
Dr. Zhan,
just had a question for you.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I
think one of the challenges of resistance to RAS
is just the complexity.
Absolutely.
Not
like EGFR, where you see a predominant mutation.
In your models, was there a
predominant one that kind of emerged across all these different cell lines, or
was it just
there wasn't anything specific?
At this point, we see various, as you
said, is a multiple pathway event.
So what we are doing now is we're moving these cell lines into the
animals, and then we're trying to do downstream and
genomic and proteonomic analysis, trying to see if we can pin down to
a specific pathway. But it's unlikely to be
a single pathway-driven event. It's probably a multiple pathway
involved. So that's why it's very difficult to treat.
Hello. Yep. So I have two question.
Mm-hmm.
So what's your insight about the KRAS secondary mutation
in the resistant patient cohort?
I wonder what's the clinical relevance, when you establish the
Y64 mutant
models. And second question is, have you ever test the
MEK inhibitor in other MAPK mutant cell models, and
also the induced jaw model you just shown?
Yeah, I think the two questions we can probably answer with one
answer. And the Y64 is one event
that can be quite easily treated with a MEK inhibitor.
So earlier on, we have tested the MEK1/2 inhibitor.
That seems quite effective for the
Y64 mutant cell lines. That provide a potential
combination
strategy for clinics.
Thank you.
Yeah.
All right. Anybody else?
Okay. Thank you, Dr. Zhan.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
All right. Our next speaker is Dr.
Colin Lindsey,
and his talk will be from the Institute of Cancer Research, UK.
His talk will be on the Genomics England 100,000 Genomes Program,
allele-specific KRAS mutational signatures define distinct
subtypes in lung adenocarcinoma.
Dr. Lindsey? Here.
Is it Dr. Silvia?
Sorry.
Dr. Palladino. Sorry about that.
So it's Dr. Silvia Palladino, and she will be talking
about combining RAS inhibitors with RNR
inhibitor to prevent emergence of extrachromosomal DNA-driven
resistance.
Good afternoon, everyone. So these are my disclosures.
About 45% of colorectal cancers have KRAS
mutations. Nowadays, we have a plethora of RAS
inhibitors, but so far only the two KRAS g12c
inhibitors, sotorasib and adagrasib, have been approved with a
good efficacy in those 1000 cancer.
However, in colorectal cancer, they have more limited efficacy due to the
reactivation of EGFR.
In this regard, the CRYSTAL-1 clinical trial showed that the
combination of adagrasib plus the anti-EGFR antibody
cetuximab overall correlate with better response, and no
patient in this treatment group experienced progressive disease.
Thus, this led to the approval of sotorasib plus panitumumab and the
accelerated approval of adagrasib plus cetuximab to treat
KRAS g12c colorectal cancers.
But however, eventually resistance emerges, and we show that the
time on treatment is shorter in those patients with acquired
oncogene amplifications. To illustrate, patient
12 and patient 31, after an initial response,
experienced rapid progression, and at progression, we detected
high level of KRAS and MET amplifications on tumor tissue,
likely driven by ecDNA.
We validated these observations in two MSS colorectal cancer
human cell line, RW7213 and C106,
that we made resistant to sotorasib plus cetuximab, and as
depicted in this graph, the RW7213 became resistant
faster compared to the C106.Our resistance, the
RW7213 acquired high level of KRAS
amplifications, while the C106 became resistant by acquiring
a new point mutation on NRAS, but no oncogene amplifications.
Metaphase FISH also show that in the RW7213
resistance, the high level of KRAS amplifications were
ecDNA-driven, and yet the
RW7213 parental as well were proven to be ecDNA
positive, even though only the resistant had acquired the
ecDNA-driven KRAS amplifications.
This led us to conclude that probably the percentage baseline of
ecDNA might have promoted more rapid emergence of resistance in the
RW7213 compared to the C106, that
in the other end, were proven to be ecDNA and oncogene
amplifications negative.
Then we treated our RW7213 parental and
resistant with adagrasib and the pan RASi
inhibitor deraxurib.
As you can see from this graph, while the parental were sensitive to both the
inhibitors, the RW7213 resistant were proven to be
already cross-resistant to these inhibitors, even without a previous
exposure. And we validated these observations also
in the high microsatellite unstable colorectal cancer cell line
GP2D, that in this case we made resistant to the KRAS
G12D off inhibitor MRTX1133.
Once again, conversely to the parental that were proven to be
sensitive to the KRAS G12D on inhibitor zoldurasib and
deraxurib, the resistant were proven already to be
cross-resistant to both the inhibitors.
Therefore, we aimed to improve RAS target therapies in
colorectal cancer by trying to
inhibiting at the same time RAS signaling and the emergence of oncogene
amplifications. And to do so, we combined different RAS inhibitors
with BBI 825 by Boundless Bio,
which is a selective and oral inhibitor of the ribonucleotide reductase, the
limiting enzyme in the de novo biosynthesis of nucleotide.
So we assumed that by lowering the amount of available
nucleotide, we could induce DNA replication stress and cell
cytotoxicity, especially in those cells and tumors that are ecDNA
positive, and therefore likely more sensitive to the
depletion of the NTPs.
Preliminary results from a resistant induction experiment in the murine cell
line CT26 showed that we were able to delay the emergence
of resistance to MRTX1133, zoldurasib, and
deraxurib by combining BBI 825 with these RAS
inhibitors. And this effect was associated with a suppression of
KRAS amplifications in the cells treated with
MRTX1133 plus BBI 825, and a
reduction of copy number alterations of both KRAS and
RAF1 in the cells treated with either zoldurasib or deraxurib
plus BBI 825.
Then we decided to test this combinatorial treatment in our
RW7213, knowing that they are prone to acquire high level
of KRAS amplifications.
Therefore, we treated the RW7213 with increasing doses of
sotorasib, adagrasib, or deraxurib combined with
cetuximab, with or without BBI 825.
And we saw that the addition of BBI 825 to sotorasib and
adagrasib plus cetuximab completely prevented the emergence of
resistance to the point that we were not able to get any
resistant subclone from this combinatorial treatment.
While the combination of BBI 825 with deraxurib plus
cetuximab delayed the emergence of resistance and the cell doubling
time.
We hypothesized that this effect correlates with the ability of BBI
825 to suppress the emergence of KRAS amplifications, as
evidenced by the fact that only in the RW7213
treated with the combination of deraxurib plus cetuximab plus BBI
825, we did not observe any KRAS amplifications.
We are currently performing the same experiment on the C106, and
we are observing that the combination of BBI with the RAS
inhibitors is delaying the emergence of resistance, especially when BBI
825 is combined with sotorasib or adagrasib plus cetuximab.
Conversely, resistance emergence was not affected by the
combination of BBI 825 with RAS inhibitors in the GP2D.
That in line with a high microsatellite instability, become
resistant by acquiring new point mutations instead of oncogene
amplifications.
On the basis of these premises, we then decided to challenge the combinatorial
treatment also in cell-derived xenografts.
And in line with in vitro data, we were able to prevent the emergence of
resistance in the xenografts from the CT26 by combining
BBI 825 with adagrasib. And this effect was once
again associated with a suppression of KRAS amplifications.
This ability of BBI 825 to repress
the emergence of oncogene amplifications was also confirmed in
xenografts from the RW7213.
Here we were able to significantly delay the emergence of
resistance by combining BBI 825 to adagrasib plus
cetuximab. And once again, we saw that this effect was
associated with a suppression of oncogene amplifications, in this case of
MEK.
As expected by the in vitro results,
the combination of BBI 825 plus MRTX1133
and cetuximab did not affect the emergence of resistance in the
GP2D-derived xenograft.
In parallel, we also generated a patient-derived
xenograft, CLR142 parental.
As you can see from this graph curve, the CLR142 parental were
already very sensitive to sotorasib plus cetuximab, but the addition of
BBI 825 further enhanced the efficacy of the
therapy. And this effect was associated with a decrease of
expression of c-MYC and a high inhibition of p90RSK
phosphorylation.Lastly, from the same patient, but at
progression, we derived the CLR142 resistance
characterized by having high level of KRAS amplifications.
Here, the combination of BBI 825 to sotorasib plus cetuximab
slowed down tumor growth, but without meeting statistical significance.
Even though we were not able to completely revert resistance in this model,
we saw by metaphase FISH that in the tumor treated with a combination of
sotorasib plus cetuximab, in addition to BBI 825,
we were able to achieve a significant suppression of KRAS
amplifications. So to conclude,
here I showed you that high level of amplifications overall correlate with
more rapid emergence of resistance, and that unfortunately, the emergence of
resistance to one RAS target therapy might promote more broad
cross-resistance. However, the combination of BBI
825 with different RAS inhibitors was able to delay or completely
prevent the emergence of resistance in our MSS CRC models.
And even though we were not able to completely revert resistance, we showed
that BBI 825 was able to limit genomic instability in our
CLR142 resistant model. With this, I'd like to thank
all the Boundless Bio group team and all my team at Memorial
Sloan Kettering. Thank you.
Questions for Dr. Polidoro?
Let's see.
I have a question.
So you showed that how you are trying to prevent acquired
resistance by using this combination.
Did you do all your studies in
KRAS inhibitor-resistant models or KRAS
inhibitor-naive models?
No, the models for the long-term growth curves, for example, the
RW7213, they were actually parental, so they were
sensitive to the drug, and we induced the resistance.
And we saw that there was a difference in the emergence of resistance that can be
either prevented or delayed by
treating the cells in combination with BBI 825 plus the RAS inhibitors.
Okay, I think we have one chance for last questions, you all.
This is a very interesting combo.
All right. Thank you, Dr. Polidoro.
All right.
Sorry about that, guys. I think I merged another RAS
combo meeting when I was making those announcements. Okay.
Our next speaker is Dr. Zhao, and he's going to be speaking on
targeting the JAK-STAT pathway that
sensitizes KRAS mutant cancer to KRAS inhibitors. Dr.
Zhao.
Yeah.
Hello, everyone. I'm Yi Zhao, and I'm from Pancreas Center, Ruijin
Hospital, affiliate to Shanghai Jiao Tong University School of Medicine,
and no need to disclose. And today I will have mainly three
parts. First, about the background.
So from the left panel, we can know that KRAS is a very important
oncogene widely in a lot of cancer types like pancreas
cancer, colon cancer, lung cancer.
And in PDAC, I mean pancreas cancer, they are 90% of
patients have the KRAS mutation. And
in the PDAC patients, G12D is a very important mutation
since it's
43% of patients. And
previously, KRAS is thought undruggable.
However, these years, there are a lot of achievements about the KRAS inhibitors.
And today, I will focus on the KRAS G12D.
So the right one is a compound we used in our project.
It is HRS4642. It's an intrawiners
G12D inhibitor. And now in Ruijin Hospital, we are doing
the phase two clinical trial using the
HRS4642 G12D inhibitor combined with pardusol
and gemcitabine for neoadjuvant chemotherapy.
And I want to show some results from the Hengrui Company. Sorry.
HRS4642 is a compound from Hengrui Company
in Shanghai. And
so last year, the data showed that when they used the
G12D inhibitor combined with gemcitabine and pardusol in
advanced PDAC patients, they can achieve a very good
result, like 60% of OR and nearly
100% of DCR.
Yeah. So second part is how we found the JAK1/STAT3
pathway is involved in the resistance mechanism.
So firstly, the story begins from
the in vitro acquired resistance model.
We culture the lines with increasing levels of
MRT1133, the first-in-class
G12D inhibitor. And finally, they got the resistance not only
to the pinras inhibitor ARMc6236, but also to the G12D
inhibitor.
And also not about the cell viability, but also the phospho-S6 and
the phospho-ERK, the main downstreams of KRAS, also shows
the resistance to the KRAS inhibitor, and the baseline also show
a high activation about the phospho-S6 and phospho-ERK.
So now we want to know why, which cause the mechanism.
So the Buck RNA-seq and the ATAC-seq found that
JAK/STAT pathway is upregulated in the resistant line.
And for translational value, we
did a FDA-approved compound library screening.
So I will explain that.
Firstly, we just see the parental line, I mean,
sensitive line and
the resistant line individually in the place, and then treated
them with compounds all FDA-approved.
And then we just selected the compounds which can cure the
line with more than 50%. And most importantly,
we compare the compound's effect on KRAS
resistant line and the KRAS parental line.
And then we just compare and use compounds to identify the
activity and do synergy test. And finally, we found that STAT3
inhibitor really shows the
killing effect on resistant lines better than the parental
line.And we do the Western blot validation we found that
JAK1 and phospho STAT3 was upregulated in the resistant line,
the baseline. And also using the STAT3 inhibitor, the
resistant cell line show on vulnerability to the STAT3 inhibitor.
And also we don't only focus on the acquired resistance,
we also focus on the primary resistance.
So we do the phospho proteomics using the on curance
inhibitor to treat the PDAC line, and you can see that phospho S6 and
MAPK, the ERK, they are downregulated and when you
treat them with the curance inhibitor and the quality control.
And also the STAT3 just upregulates very
well good. And
so different time point treat with curance inhibitor will cause a very robust
phospho STAT3 activation. And also in the right panel, we
use the STAT3 inhibitor. We found that it can block the phospho
STAT3. And also we can expand that to murine
line in the lung cancer JTLC line and in the
PDAC JTLD line. And also because STAT3 is a
important transcription factor, also
acute curance inhibition will cause one
upregulation of the epigenomics and the STAT3 inhibitor will just make
them go to nearly baseline. And also STAT3 is a
very important pathway just regulating the secreted proteins.
And we found that very impressively interleukin-6,
well studied as it
can be secreted by the activation of STAT3, and
also it can activate STAT3. So yeah, interleukin-6
and STAT3, they will have a positive loop.
And you can see curance inhibitor just increase the
secretion level of interleukin-6.
And combined with STAT3 inhibitor, it will block that very
good. And ELISA validation just show that.
And then we just go to the translational.
So of all the STAT3 inhibitor, we selected a lot of compounds and finally we
used this compound. This one is a oral bioavailable STAT3
inhibitor targeting the
two phosphorylation sites, Y705 and S727,
the most important phosphorylation sites of STAT3.
And most importantly is that the compound's
effect is related to the activation level of STAT3.
It means if you acquire resistance,
there are high level of phospho STAT3, or you use curance inhibitor
to cause a acute upregulation of
phospho STAT3, the compounds will be more effective because
the high level of phospho STAT3. And we just do
some in vitro synergy studies. Left one is in the
murine lines, and they grow very fast and use the curance
inhibitor combined with the compound we said, they
can achieve very good results. And
so the right one is the synergy results summary.
We don't only use the curance inhibitor combined with STAT3 inhibitor.
We also try the JAK1 inhibitor like the tofacitinib, and it
shows very good effect on the block of the phospho STAT3 and the cell
viability.
So the
best data we got is on KPC subcutaneous
CDX model. So single STAT3 inhibitor
cause some control but not very good.
And single curance inhibitor use HRS-4642, they can
achieve
two over six complete response.
And however, after three or four weeks, they will finally
relapse. And at that time, the single curance
group, we just change that to the combined group and it
shows a very good effect. The tumor just all shrinking.
And the
combined group from the beginning always show very good
complete response effect. And also we try some GM
model. We try KPC model and KCC model.
So KCC model is one model we used in our center.
It's combined with KRAS G12D and CDK2F
knockout. And this model features on a more
sharp survival curve. So you can see
curance inhibitor
cure a lot. However, it finally die, and the combination shows a better
effect.
And we also try some PDX model from our center.
They have different
genetic background, and the combination always shows a better
effect.
And in the parental CDX
or in the resistant CDX, you can see single curance inhibitor can
achieve a very good effect in the parental
CDX model. And in the resistant model, we use the combination, and it
shows a good effect.
And we also try the combination to other
murine model like the colon cancer and lung cancer.
So the results is not good like the PDAC
model, but it still shows some synergy effect.
So conclusion is that JAK1/STAT3 pathway is very
important for both acute and chronic, acquired
resistance responses. And for translational
medicine, so co-targeting JAK1/STAT3, mainly
targeting STAT3, can enhance the effect of curance
inhibitor. And yeah, I want to acknowledge my mentor in
China, Professor Shen Baiyun. He is the vice president of Shanghai Region Hospital.
And every year we have more than 3,000 WHIP operations
just focusing on the PDAC patients, and there are a lot of clinical trials
focusing on the curance inhibitor and the
KRAS mRNA vaccine. So thank you.
Questions for
Dr. Xiao?Dr. Zhao,
the oral STAT3 inhibitor, do you know if it's in
the clinic now?
Yeah.
And do you know what kind of toxicities?
The reason I say that, there have been other STAT3 inhibitors in the past.
There was an sRNA from a company
AstraZeneca had developed, AZD9150.
There are some other oral STAT inhibitors that have been--
The safety was
somewhat suspect, so I'm curious as to
this Chinese oral STAT3.
Okay. So the compound is from Yuyao Technique, and
I believe their compounds are in the phase one clinical trial.
The safety is okay, but just the efficacy.
And so in our preclinical model, I don't see any adverse
effect. The tumor rate is always very good and,
yeah, in the combination group. Sorry.
Question there at that microphone.
Hi. Over here.
Yeah. Thank you.
So I was a little confused with the resistance model that you
showed in the second or third to last slide, where
you showed that there was no effect of the KRAS inhibitor or the
STAT3 inhibitor as single agents, but in combination with one
another, you got tumor shrinkage.
So do you know mechanistically how that works?
You mean
why the JAK starter is-
Could you speak into the microphone so I can hear you a little bit?
Sorry. Can you repeat that?
Yeah. So in the third to last slide, you showed a
resistance model-
Yeah
... in which the treatment with the KRAS inhibitor had no effect,
this treatment with the STAT3 inhibitor had no effect, but the combination
together had an effect.
Okay. So-
So mechanistically, how does that work?
Yeah. Okay. So first thing is that the only
resistance CDX model I used is ASPC1, and I believe that
ASPC1, they have a very lower baseline of p4
STAT3. Compared to other resistance CDX models, they don't show a very
high level of p4 STAT3, so maybe it'll explain why the
single STAT3 inhibitor doesn't cause a very good in vivo effect.
And secondly, I think STAT3 is always related to
immune. So yeah, the resistance CDX is just
one human model, so it doesn't activate
the immune system, so maybe it'll
explain why it's a combination.
Single STAT3 doesn't achieve a very good result is my-
And then just a quick follow-up question.
Did you, in those tumors, look at
phospho-ERK or phospho-STAT3 or something
downstream of STAT3 to actually understand about the
modulation of the pathways where the two single
agents had no effect, but the combination works?
So we harvested the PDF file, I mean, poster, those
file-based
samples to do the Western blot, and it shows a very similar effect,
similar to in vitro. But under the Clearpow doesn't show a lot,
but the long-term efficacy shows the results.
Okay. Thank you very much.
Okay.
I think we'll move on. Thank you. Thank you, Dr. Zhao.
Thank you.
The next speaker is Dr. Sung Yun Wong
from Seoul National University, who will be
talking about VEGF R2 blockade
overcomes acquired KRAS G12D inhibitor resistance driven
by PIK3 gamma activation.
Thank you for the opportunity to present our work.
Today, I will discuss how two VEGF R2 blockade can overcome
acquired resistance to
MRTX833.
The central message of this study is a resistant
model become defender in the PI3K gamma, drive in
VEGF-A, VEGF RPR activation, and
the blockade of this axis become
therapeutically overcome.
I have nothing to disclosure.
This study was designed to answer three questions.
First, what is the key resistant mechanism
of MRTX833? Second, what is
the molecular event sustained VEGF-A,
VEGF R2 activation? Third,
can this resistance be overcome therapeutically?
At
Korea Cell Line Bank established the
MRTX833 resistant
collector patient-derived organoid and perform single-cell
RNAseq. Then, Dr. Eun Jung Lee and
Min Kyung Bae distinguished the parental and resistant cluster
based on their proportion.
TSVA demonstrate
angiogenesis, JAK-STAT, hypoxia, and
EMT signature were increased in resistant model
and among the genes VEGF-A, which is
a therapeutically actionable target, is
increased in resistant model.
Across all nine gastrointestinal models,
resistant model showed increased phosphorylated VEGF
R2 and VEGF R2.
In line with that, RMC9805 resistant cell
showed increased phosphorylated VEGF R2 and VEGF
R2.
Consistently, VEGF-A levels in conditioned media were
increased in MRTX833
levels.Next,
to ask
increased VEGF-R2 is functionally important in
resistant model, we
generated inducible VEGF-R2 knockout
resistant cells. When VEGF-R2 knockout,
anti-proliferative effect of
MRTX1133 is increased
and comparable results were obtained after treatment
with
VEGF-R2 inhibitor remucirumab. This data suggests that
VEGF-R2 is not simply increased in resistant model,
but serve as a therapeutically actionable vulnerability.
Next, we observed in resistant models,
VEGF-A promoter activity were increased compared to parental model
and SP1, which is a transcription
factor of VEGF-A, were increased compared to
increase in resistant cells compared to parental cells.
Notably,
deletion of SP1 binding site on VEGF promoter region
reduced the VEGF-A transcription level and
VEGF-R2 activation.
When SP1 knocked down VEGF-A, VEGF-R2
activity were decreased and sensitivity to
MRTX1133 is increased. This indicate
SP1 and
nuclear localization increase the
VEGF transcription and VEGF-R2
activation.
In resistant models, KRAS protein expression and activity were
increased compared to parental cells,
while MRTX1133 decreased the activity in
parental model,
but resistant model showed
still higher level.
In line with that, PI3K level also
increased in resistant model
and still maintained their level after treatment with
MRTX1133.
As downstream mechanism, AKT phosphorylation were also
increased.
Next, we figure out which PI3K catalytic and
regulatory subunit were associated with KRAS.
In resistant model, KRAS showed significant increased
binding with P101
compared to parental cell, and
was accompanied by stronger association with P110
gamma.
This finding indicated KRAS, P110 gamma and
P101 complex were
preferentially formed in resistant models.
Notably, inhibition of PI3K gamma with aconitase
decreased VEGF-A, VEGF-R2 activity, and increased the
sensitivity to MRTX1133.
Also, remucirumab treatment decreased the AKT phosphorylation.
Tied together, our data support the following model.
KRAS, P110 gamma and P101 complex
formed in resistant model and activated PI3K
signaling that increased the AKT phosphorylation.
It promotes the SP1 nuclear localization and
promotes the VEGF-A
transcription and activity.
In turn,
activated VEGF-R2 functions as an autocrine
signaling loop and reinforces the PI3K gamma
signaling.
Next,
using a co-culture of PDOs with human conditioned
media
followed by the Burker RNA-seq, we found that
resistant PDO's relative condition strengths the
angiogenesis and EMT, and increase the
proliferation close to human cells.
In reciprocal experiment,
exposure to resistant PDO conditioned media
increased the proliferative programs in
human cell, including E2F and MYC
targeted signatures, and increased the
proliferation.
This schematic summarize
paracrine crosstalk between endothelial and cancer cells.
Endothelial cell drive signal reinforces the
angiogenesis and EMT in cancer cells, and
cancer cell drive the conditioned media
promotes the proliferation in human
cells.
To evaluate
blockade of VEGF-R2 can overcome
MRTX1133 resistant in mouse model,
we established the PANCO-1 parental
resistant mouse model and treated with
MRTX1133 and DC101,
which is a VEGF-R2 inhibitor, and their combination.
After 15 days later, in parental model,
combination therapy showed a similar tumor growth inhibition
compared to MRTX1133 monotherapy.
However,
in a resistant model, combination therapy showed
significantly greater tumor growth inhibition compared to
either monotherapy.
Importantly, additional two model using
AGS and SNUC2B resistant model showed
consistently decreased
the tumor growth, and this effect was extend
to 45
days.Immunofluorescence
staining of PANCO1 resistance model showed
VEGF R2 blockade decreased the proliferation markers
in cancer cells and endothelial cells compared to
MRTXA1133 group. And
VEGF R2 inhibition also decreased the
EMT features in cancer cells. This effect
were furtherly increased by in combination
therapy group.
In summary,
in resistance cells, VEGF-A, VEGF R2 signaling is a
common feature,
and SP1 driving VEGF-A transcription
increased the VEGF-A, VEGF R2 signal activation.
This is driven by K-RAS, P110 gamma, and
P11 complex reinforces an autocrine
VEGF R2
loop. In addition,
cancer endothelial paracrine crosstalk
promotes the pro-tumorigenic environment.
Overall,
dual inhibition of VEGF R2 and K-RAS
overcome the MRTXA1133 in preclinical models.
A sincere thank you to our
laboratory and institutional members
for making this work possible.
Thank you for attention.
Questions for Dr. Huang?
Yeah.
Dr. Huang, I don't know if you are aware, but
Revolution Medicine now has a trial of a
combination of ivanissimab, which is the VEGF R
P1
bispecific,
with
RMC-9805, and also
RMC-6236 or dexonrasib.
What would you hypothesize? Do you think that you would also see additional
synergy with P1 in this case?
You
mean the combination with-
With the bispecific, like ivanissimab, yeah.
Yeah. I guess that also be
more synergistic because our findings suggest a
VEGF signal was increased in resistance
model, so bispecific inhibitor for VEGF
could be more synergistic compared to monotherapy.
Okay.
Other questions?
Okay. Thank you, Dr. Huang.
One more, sorry.
We have one more person. There you go.
There's Dr.-
How general do you think this mechanism is?
And
have you seen the same biology in other cell lines, models,
or clinical specimens?
Could you say it again?
Sure. How general is this mechanism of
K-RAS resistance, and have you seen it in other cell
lines or other models or
even in some clinical evidence of it in clinical specimens?
We
using nine gastrointestinal models
using six cancer cell line and three cancer
patient-derived organoid.
That show the same result. Same increase
the VEGF-A, VEGF R2 activation, and the K-RAS
P110 gamma and P11 complex.
And
three mouse model also show that synergism after two monthly
combination. So I think
this result a
general mechanism in resistance.
Thanks.
All right. Thank you again, Dr. Huang.
All right. Last talk of this amazing
session. This is Dr. Li, Chendu Li from Mass General.
She's going to talk about targeted therapy-induced chromosomal
instability dictates mitotic dependency on Aurora
kinase A. Dr.
Li.
Thank you so much.
This is an honor for me to speak here.
So most of the targeted therapy inhibit oncogenic
signaling and eliminate the cancer cell.
However, at the same time, they also induce collateral cellular stress
in these remaining tumor cells. For example, the replication,
oxidative, ER, or metabolic stress.
And recent study have been started to suggest that the DNA
damage can also be induced by targeted therapy in these
studies.
Importantly, in this study, most of the
study were highly sensitive cancer models.
However, less is clear about whether targeted therapy can
also induce DNA damage in less sensitive cancer
models. Those include more cytostatic clinical
setting.
And K-RAS inhibitor, despite its advance in the clinic,
have limited efficacy as we know. And
in patient as well as the preclinical models, these
K-RAS inhibitor often predominantly have more
cytostatic than cytotoxic response.
So we asked whether K-RAS G12C inhibitor can induce DNA
damage, and whether because DNA damage can
cause chromosomal instability, which is a key resource
for metastasis and therapeutic resistance.
So we also asked whether K-RAS inhibitor can cause
chromosomal instability, also known as CIN, and whether they
can create specific therapeutic vulnerabilities that can
be exploited.So
to test that, we profiled 15 KRAS G12C mutant non-small
cell lung cancer cell lines with diverse COPI mutations, and
we treat the cell with G12C inhibitor
LY3499446, a
olaparib compound, a tool compound from Eli Lilly,
and assess the DNA damage via gamma-H2AX
staining. And as you can see, G12C inhibitor definitely
induce the DNA damage in cells.
However, in different cell lines, the kinetics and magnitude
are very different, where some cells you see a profound
increase in the DNA damage, while in others it's more of a
transient response.
While DNA damage can cause chromosomal instability, we then
test micronuclear formation as a
chromosomal instability marker.
And similarly to the DNA damage result, we also
see that in some cell lines there are induction of the
micronuclei, while in other cell lines we do not see it.
And of note, neither DNA damage nor chromosomal
instability at baseline or induced
correlate with the KRAS G12C inhibitor monotherapy
sensitivity.
Given the heterogeneous response of DNA damage and
chromosomal instability we observe, we ask whether that can create
some exploitable vulnerabilities.
So we screen compounds that are targeting SIN,
and we chose the sub-lethal dosing of this compound, and then
combined with KRAS G12C inhibitor and calculate the
synergy.
As you can see in this heat map, there are multiple synergy
between KRAS G12C inhibitor and multiple SIN targeting
compound in a very heterogeneous way.
But within those, the aurora kinase A inhibitor,
LSN3321213, marks a
greatest synergy with KRAS G12C inhibitor, which is also
positively correlate with the micronuclei
induction in these cells.
Of note, this aurora kinase A inhibitor we use in
this study has 1,500 more times of
affinity to aurora kinase A than aurora kinase B,
compared to the previously described pan-aurora kinase inhibitors.
We also validate our finding via clonogenic assay
and show that combined G12C and aurora kinase A inhibition
can lead to the suppression of clonal formation.
And this synergy can be achieved by using very low
dose of the aurora kinase A inhibitor as low as 10 nanomolar.
We also did our work in the cell line xenograft and
PDX xenograft and showed that this combination can cause tumor
regression as well as
improve the relapse-free for survival, but we cannot show this data as
of this presentation.
So together, this data really suggested that a KRAS G12C inhibitor induced
SIN in a subset of non-small cell lung cancer model that
confer a selective vulnerability to aurora kinase A inhibition.
We then start to understand the mechanism of synergy.
So previous report suggested that the resistant
tumor cell can activate aurora kinase A signaling
and drive adaptive resistance, either by phosphorylating
CRAF and MAP kinase signaling, as well as degradation
of pro-apoptotic protein Bim to avoid
apoptosis. We tested both of these mechanism in our
cell line and did not observe a consistent result across the
panel of model we tested.
Well, given the role of aurora kinase A in mitotic progression, we
then instead hypothesized that the KRAS G12C
inhibition may create a mitotic vulnerability that is
dependent on aurora kinase A function.
So to test that hypothesis, we utilize the single-cell
time-lapse imaging together with CDK2 activity
to label cell cycle as well as the H2B to
label the cell death and track the cell after they get a
treatment, and this was a collaboration with Dr.
Spencer's group at the University of Colorado.
As you can see, the vehicle-treated cells cycles normally,
and G12C inhibitor-treated cells have marked
G0/G1 arrest. Aurora kinase A cause
prolonged G2/M arrest. The combination of cells cause a
lot of cell death, and the majority of the death
event actually happens after the mitotic arrest,
as you show here by the fluctuation of CDK2 low and
high dribbling activity.
So this data suggested that the G12C inhibitor might prime
aurora kinase A-dependent mitotic catastrophe.
How does G12C prime this catastrophe?
So to answer that question, we pretreat the cell with G12C
inhibitor and aurora kinase A inhibitor and synchronize them
at the prometaphase, and then did mitotic shake-off,
and then watch the cell afterwards.
And as you can see, the vehicle-treated cell pass through mitosis very
normally. G12C can slow down mitosis for a little bit,
and the aurora kinase A cause mitotic arrest.
Prolonged treatment of the aurora kinase A inhibitor actually create these
polyploid cells, suggesting that aurora kinase A is
indeed causing mitotic slippage.
So this data suggested that the G12C inhibitor actually
sways away the cell from aurora kinase A-induced
division or slippage towards mitotic
catastrophe.But how do GTOX
inhibitor determine that cell fate?
Well, the established theory has suggested that
for a mitotic cell to determine its cell fate, it's
determined by a balance of the cyclin B1 dynamics and the
death signal. So rapid degradation of cyclin B1 will cause
cells to slip or divide, and the slow degradation of cyclin B1
will cause cell to undergo catastrophe.
So,
consistent with that theory, we have shown that GTOX inhibitor-treated cell
have elevated cyclin B1 level at the onset of
mitosis, and this progress through the entire mitosis,
while the proapoptotic protein BIM
not have any difference.
And then we ask, how does GTOX inhibitor stabilize the cyclin
B1? So, in fact, the DNA
damage during mitosis can activate
DNA repair pathway ATR and CHEK1, which may
stabilize the cyclin B1 through APCC cofactor
CDH1.
To test whether ATM, ATR, DNA repair pathway
contribute to our phenotype, we knock ATM, ATR down
and notice that that can completely reverse the cell death phenotype
bring out by the combination.
And the cells with ATR knockdown can also reduce the cyclin B1
accumulation induced by KRAS GTOX inhibitor.
And the cell with deficient ATR can also
pass through mitosis much quickly, escaping both
GTOX-induced mitotic slowing as well as aura kinase
A-induced mitotic arrest.
When we isolate the mitotic fraction of the micronuclei
high versus low cells, we notice that in the micronuclei high cells,
they induce activated ATR phosphorylation or ATM
phosphorylation that does not happen in the micronuclei low
cells.
So together, our data has formed this model where in the
low SYN cells, GTOX inhibitor may induce DNA
damage, but they can be resolved. So the cells can escape the
aura kinase A arrest by slippage or division.
And for the SYN high cells, however, the GTOX inhibitor
cause mitotic DNA damage which cannot be resolved,
and that will track into the mitosis, activate
ATM, ATR, and cause cyclin B1 stabilization
and mitotic catastrophe.
And hopefully our
study can show that GTOX inhibitor-induced
SYN as a predictive marker of response to combined KRAS
GTOX and aura kinase A inhibition, and hope our study can
provide a mechanistic rationale to enhance
the therapeutic window for aura kinase A inhibitor when used
with other targeted therapies. And you can find my study on the bio
archive.
So this is just an example of how
targeted therapy-induced stress cause synthetic vulnerability, but
it's also very interesting to know whether there are other
stress signaling pathway that can be used for a
biomarker-driven synthetic vulnerability.
And I'm also excited to study how stressing these
different factors can dictate the evolution of
drug-tolerant persistor cells in my future studies.
So I am on the job market, so please email me
or add me on LinkedIn, and please, if you have
a position.
So I wanted to thank my mentor, Dr. Aaron Hata, and
the rest of the lab members at MGH Cancer Center.
And I want to thank my collaborators.
And I'm happy to take any questions.
Michelle Front.
Nice talk. This is Angie Wang Gillam. I have two question.
One is, I think Eli Lilly's drug with a KRAS G12C
inhibitor plus AURKA inhibitor is not moving forward.
Is that right, or is that just because they are not selecting
particular subtype?
So they still keep the study of the combination of
the G12C with the AURA A to be continued, but the
monotherapy aura kinase A inhibitor is discontinued.
I think partially because of dose-limiting toxicities.
Second question also.
Is this a very general mechanism, for instance,
other mutation or mutant-specific
inhibitor such as the KRAS G12D?
So this is a good question. So we think that this could be a
general mechanism as long as that targeted therapy is induced
some kind of chromosomal instability.
So if they do, of course, the cell is going to respond to
the aura kinase A inhibitor.
It's a dependency.
Anybody else?
Yeah, over here on the left.
Yes, yes.
Hi, Jackson Fotheree from Fred Hutch Cancer Center. Great talk, Chendi.
Pretty interested, given the links between chromosomal instability and
cGAS-STING signaling and in general inflammation-
Mm-hmm.
Comment on how a patient who might induce
chromosome instability under G12C inhibition might respond to
immunotherapy in the clinic.
Well,
so first regarding to the cGAS-STING pathway activation,
I think there are definitely a long-term
cGAS-STING activation versus short-term.
So I just wanted to clarify here that the
targeted therapy-induced chromosomal instability in our case is not
a chronic response. So, we
don't care about whether the STING will go down afterwards.
So this is a transient response. And then second, for the
immunotherapy combination,
I think there's evidence in the clinic that KRAS G12C
and the PD1 inhibitor can combine very well already.
So I think the fact is already there in the clinic, so.
Yeah, great.
Yeah.
All right.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
Ellen, thank you so much for... And
just to note, you are on the job market. Yes, thank you.
All right.
Okay, I think, wow, we ended a little bit
early. My only final comment is it is an
incredibly exciting time in the RAS
field. And I think many of you guys have seen
some of the recent announcements from Revolution Medicine given their
daxonrasib and second line PDAC. I think we will
see many more
incredible
RAS inhibitors,
and my guess is really the next reiteration of this will
be just really impactful combinations.
So thank you again for coming. Just a plug, there is also a RAS
meeting at the NCI this coming October.
So if you can make it, please join us. All right. Thank you guys.